[Music]
this is the chicken Maharaja I guess
it's like they're a Big Mac must be
there's a lot of bun here I don't think
this is the same sauce they use in a Big
Mac it can't be it's chicken it's not
beef but what can you do this is this is
amazing this is
this is American opulence exported to
India at its finest this is just like
yeah let's just put all of it in there
like what the hell it's actually a lot
better than I thought
so here we have the McHale Louie burger
a loose potato so I'm assuming gonna be
a lot of potato in here get the
McDonald's quality I've come to learn -
it looks like I bro you're in the u.s.
kind of so it was sad looking I don't
know what that tastes like
just some good good flavors that I
associate with India what's interesting
about this is that I've absolutely no
idea what is in this the inside of the
patty is green the sauce is orange and
it's covered in onions and like you know
there's so many vegetarians in India
obviously they have to make some veg
vegetarians so good deal this is the big
spicy chicken wrap this is American
science it's confusing harder I think
it's like
[Music]
we're sexual pretty close to what it is
new a bit more spicy but again it's all
all the sauces and mayo is it's so much
this might actually be the spiciest
thing I've ever eaten in my job and it's
like this creeping one that's like
coming up the back of my mouth
this is a 100% paneer passion week are
my feet I still love that they put them
Nick in front of everything
Nick paneer okay kind of looks like a
deep-fried french toast
a giant half though the cheese I guess
it's a cheese patty and we've got the
McDonald's India token mysterious orange
sauce come on that's spicy
[Music]
this is food that you would like just
eaten bad it like anyone but the years a
little weird but I guess it's kind of
like TOEFL in that way it just takes on
the flavor of whatever is on top of it
this is something that I think could
possibly be successful in the US
I feel like McDonald's India was like
literally put together by someone just
perusing over could be the article for
Indian food and like putting a
[Music]